>>Guys, I know.
Just take a deep breath, you guys.
Give us a few minutes, okay?
Justin, can you stop, please?
Okay. Ladies and gentlemen!
>>Narrator: Having trouble
managing your classroom?
Here are some of our
favorite tricks of the trade.
>>All right.
We're going to come to this table.
Please push in your chairs.
Come on around.
Remember, give them space.
>>Narrator: Chris Opitz
creates a fishbowl
so that students can learn lessons
in manners and math from each other.
>>Chris: Audience,
our voices are off.
We're just going to look for evidence
of a really great discussion,
and then we're going to
talk about that afterwards.
>>I began using the fishbowl having
kids really closely observe other
kids in discussion identifying
particular types of language,
ways to ask questions, how to
use manners when disagreeing,
and once that foundation is built,
then the academics can be
so much more thoughtful.
>>Mike started with 8.
Kelly had twice as much as Mike,
and Joe had half as much as Kelly.
>>Chris: Every teacher out there has
probably said at some point in time,
"Turn to your neighbor
and talk about this idea.
Look at your teammates
and talk about this idea."
>>Why did you do those shapes?
>>Chris: And really watch.
If they are talking about the topic
that you've asked them to talk about,
if they're actually listening to
each other and using that language
and those social skills, then all
of a sudden, you have an environment
where 30 kids are all
learning at the same time.
>>Narrator: Share one of your tricks
with fellow teachers on Edutopia.